named for its method of burying rotting  carcasses to feed its young this is the  gravedigger of the animal kingdom  the american burying beetle  these beetles feed on small decomposing  animals like birds and mice inside their  antennae are strong chemical receptors  that detect rotting meat  they have powerful wings and will travel  long distances to reach their meal  males and females work together to bury  the corpse and females will then lay her  eggs nearby  after the larvae hatch both parents tend  to their young a behavior rarely found  in insects  once a prolific beetle found in over 35  states across the u.s today it can be  found in just six listed as endangered  back in 1989 the american bering  beetle's future is bleak while  conservation efforts are underway there  is still a long way to go this is the  american bering beetle  [Music]  you